So, Sarah. You've been with us for five years.
Correctly.
I see amazing effort and diligence ... mhm.
I'll read it later.
So, I invited you to my office to talk a little bit about
your future! Great, I think I know where you're going ....
Especially as for Steava.
Uh, Steve, uh, the internist?
Yeah, Steve, damn best internist of all time.
[giggles]
Actually, it reminds me when I was a kid.
Anyway, we just hired him as a junior manager
and I'd like you to show him how.
Uh. Is there any reason why I wasn't considered for ...
... open position?
No! Sarah, you're great where you are
and if you were serious about wanting to be promoted in the next few years,
which I - for the record - didn't know you wanted
I think you should try a little more.
Good.
(everybody is laughing)
... and I said "no way, buddy"
(laughter)
Sports! Am I right? Am I right?
Oh! Something glittering!
(Storm)
What?
(Laughter)
You all had piss ** y.
Just two seconds ago.
Hey, I really like your shoes.
Oh, thank God, I bought them at a discount!
You see, I saw them online at Nordstorm's site and they were at full price and--
(impact)
So
it looks like you had a very clear hallucination
that you lived in a world that was predominantly male-driven.
(Shaking)
You have to shake it off.
This is great !!
(the phone is ringing)
Good job Steve.
Oh, ou!
Is this something we do now?
Just if she's as sexy as Steve.
I want to have sex with you, Steve!
(Doors closing)
That was ... a simple assumption of what everyone was saying.
Don't be weird.
So, get ready to meet the new sexy face of our advertising campaign.
Wooo "
Yeah!
You look good!
I could scrub the underwear on my stomach muscles, Bill.
I feel somehow violated.
Bill, learn to accept compliments! Damn it.
(whispers) Sorry!
So, Sarah, you've been with us for five years.
Yes, that is correct.
And I'm sure I loved each of those last five years
working for you, Mrs. Chief.
Boss Lady.
Yeah, listen, uhm
Sarah, you're doing a great job and I'd love to promote you.
Yes! Thanks! I will not let you down!
But you're not ready yet!
That ... what?
You remind me a lot of myself when I first started.
And I wouldn't have come here without that extra effort,
every step of the way, trying harder, working smarter than everyone around me.
(running water)
Hey, are you okay?
You've been acting a little weird all day.
No, no, I'm fine.
Is it the weird lightning that turned all men into women?
You know about it?
Duh-doy!
You know, I was thinking ...
I wondered ... if every woman didn't have to fight
against the others in the order of that little spot
on the male desk,
that things would be so much better.
But it's like we're literally swapping places and now
we are the morons.
No no no!
The mascara waves on my lashes will not actually make them denser at all.
I had to invest months of oil care and eyelid massage,
to be denser from roots to ends.
Why don't you just fake false eyelashes--
I'm just saying that waving a magic wand to change from a guy to a woman is just a cosmetic difference
Real changes happen when we start
discuss how the problems of gender imbalance affect us all.
That was deep.
(bag zipper sound)
Here.
You might need that later.
I'm not bleeding ... but thanks.
(closing the door)